Erst mal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen und dann sprechen wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, suggen Sie bitte nicht mich zu unterbrechen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Thomas Zimemann.
Zimemann heißt das.
Wie alt ist Herr Zimemann?
67.
Ihr Geburtstatum bitte?
9. Juli 1958.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 94 Kilogramm.
1 Meter 64.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder eine Hauserstin?
Natürlich. Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Müller.
Was für Sie heute so ist Herr Zimemann? Welche Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe Bauchschmerzen.
Wie groß ist Ihr Bauchschmerzen? Können Sie mir das sagen oder zeigen?
Mein Oberbauch ist starker, aber ich möchte mich manchmal ganz bauchschmerzen.
Rechts oder links?
Unterbauch, Entschuldigung.
Ganz. Ganz unterbauchschmerzen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, Doktor, diese Schmerzen sind sehr lange, aber seit 6 Monaten sind sie immer schlimmer geworden.
Seit 2 Jahren.
Seit 2 Jahren sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten, aber in der Zeit, besonders vor 6 Monaten, sind sie immer schlimmer geworden.
Sind diese Schmerzen immer da oder gehen Sie wieder weg?
Die Schmerzen sind nicht dauerhaft. Ich fühle mich manchmal gut, aber manchmal schlecht.
Besonders die Beschwerden sind nach dem Essen 2 Stunden oder beim Stress aufgetreten.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen von 1 bis 10 auf einer Skala, wobei 10 am stärksten ist?
Doktor, es ist verschieden, aber ich denke 5 Jahre.
Momentan haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja, momentan ist es nicht schlecht, vielleicht 3 oder 4.
Waren Sie deswegen beim Arzt?
Ja, ich war oft beim Arzt, aber es wurde mir nicht richtig der Diagnose festgestellt.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente genommen?
Ja, natürlich. Ich habe viele Mal Baskopantablette angenommen, aber es wurde mir nicht geholfen.
Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Diese Schmerzen sind kolikartig und dumm.
Ich fühle mich nach dem Stuhlgang. Mein Dickdarm ist nicht leer.
Haben Sie Beläungen?
Ja, richtig. Besonders nach dem Essen habe ich ein blaues Bauch und eine blaue Hunde.
Ist Ihnen ein sauberes Ausstoß aufgefallen?
Nein, ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Atemnot, Husten?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Ist Ihnen Schluckbeschwerden aufgefallen?
Nein. Aber ich habe manchmal Durchfall, manchmal Verstopfungen.
Manchmal fühle ich mich gut, aber manchmal bin ich total erschöpft.
Momentan haben Sie Verstopfungen?
Nein, nicht jetzt. Aber wenn ich viele Mal Diora Durchfall habe, fühle ich mich sehr erschöpft.
Ist Ihnen Blut im Stuhl aufgefallen?
Nein, ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe es nicht bemerkt. Aber ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Sie fühlen sich nicht fieberig?
Ja, nicht fieberig.
Haben Sie Schüttenfrost, Nachschweiß?
Nein, Doktor, nein.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, ich habe manchmal übel. Aber ich habe keine Erbrechen.
Bisher haben Sie noch nicht Erbrechen?
Ja, jetzt nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Zimmermann?
Normalerweise gut, aber ich möchte nicht viel essen.
Ich habe gesagt, wenn ich viele Nahrung esse, nach zwei Stunden habe ich viel Blut.
Ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Deswegen habe ich in den letzten zwei Monaten ungefähr 5 Kilo in der Nahrung genommen.
Hatten Sie diese Beschwerden schon mal?
Jetzt oder?
Vorher hatten Sie das?
Ja, vor ungefähr sechs Monaten.
Sie haben seit sechs Monaten diese Schmerzen.
Außer der Ernährungsmittel, gibt es irgendetwas, das Schmerzen besser oder Schlimmer macht?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber nach dem Schüturgang sind die Schmerzen besser.
Aber nach dem Schmerzen sind die Schmerzen schlechter.
Sind die Schmerzen gewandert?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind gewandert.
Und die Schmerzen sind auch nicht schlecht.
Die Schmerzen sind besser, aber nach dem Schmerzen sind die Schmerzen schlechter.
Sind die Schmerzen gewandert?
Ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Nein.
Können Sie gut schlafen?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut.
Wenn ich nicht gut schlafe, dann schlafe ich nicht gut.
Aber Sie haben ein Schlafsturm oder ein Durchlafsturm?
Beide.
Aber Sie haben irgendwo eine chronische Krankheit?
Ja, ich habe eine Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck seit zehn Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Ich nehme eine Medikamenten täglich.
Aber jetzt weiß ich, wie die Doktor heißt.
Ich kann Ihr Hausarzt nachfragen.
Aber nur einmal täglich?
Ja, einmal täglich.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen, Herr Simmermann?
Vor drei Jahren hatte ich eine Handweginfektion.
Ich habe ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Diese Beschwerden wurden mit Antibiotik behandelt.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Verstehe. Haben Sie noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, ich habe keine Erkrankungen.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Als ich Kind war, wurde mir eine Apendektome durchgeführt.
Wie alt waren Sie?
Ich war ungefähr zehn Jahre alt.
Hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Das war alles.
Ja.
Wurde Ihnen wegen dieser Schmessen eine Sonographie durchgeführt?
Oder eine Computertomographie?
Ich habe keine Erinnerung. Nein.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Allergien? Ja, ich habe keine Allergien.
Vertragen Sie alles? Alle Lebensmitteln?
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Simmermann?
Ja, ich rauche, Doktor.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit fünf Jahren rauche ich zehn Zigaretten täglich.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Gelegentlich am Wochenende oder mit meinen Freunden treffen.
Ein Glas Sekt.
Ein Glas Sekt. Was meinen Sie mit gelegentlich?
Wie oft pro Woche oder pro Monat?
Ein oder zwei Mal pro Woche.
Ein oder zwei Glas Sekt? Ja.
Sekt.
Bitte nehmen Sie die folgenden Fragen nicht persönlich.
Aus medizinischen Gründen fragen wir immer.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Ich habe nicht Drogen probiert, Doktor.
Ich freue mich.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Simmermann?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich lebe mit meiner Frau und meinen drei Kindern.
Sie leben zusammen?
Alle sind gesund.
Gut zu hören.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Meine Eltern? Ja.
Mein Vater hatte einen Lungenkrebs.
Er ist gestorben.
Mein Beileid, Herr Simmermann.
Wegen Lungenkrebs. Wie alt war er?
Er war 69 Jahre alt.
Tut mir leid zu hören.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter lebt jetzt.
Sie hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Sie lebt jetzt in Altenheim.
Tut mir leid zu hören.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Herr Simmermann?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Waren Sie in Lesterzeit im Ausland?
Nein, aber vor drei Monaten war ich in Frankreich.
Noch eine Frage über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Sie haben gesagt, dass diese Beschwerden krampfartig sind.
Ja, krampfartig und dumm.
Wie lange dauert es, wenn Sie Schmerzen haben?
Es gibt verschiedene Doktor.
Aber ich vermute ein oder zwei Tage.
Wie lange dauert es, wenn Sie gesund sind?
Ich habe gesagt, es gibt verschiedene Doktor.
Aber ich habe mindestens 15 Attacken in Monaten.
In Monaten, jeden Monat?
Ja, jeden Monat.
Deswegen keine Sorgen.
Wir sind für Sie da.
Wir tun alles für Sie, Herr Simmermann.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, aber Doktor, ich habe gesagt, ich bin ein anderer Arzt gewesen.
Aber wir haben nicht genug Diagnose festgestellt.
Können Sie mir helfen, bitte?
Ja, wie gesagt, Herr Simmermann, wir sind für Sie da.
Wir tun alles für Sie.
Wir tun am besten für Sie.
Jetzt, das ist ein Amnesgespräch.
Danach werden wir körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann werde ich Blut abnehmen, um die Labouruntersuchungen zu machen.
Dann werde ich die Diagnostik veranlassen.
Mit dem Ergebnis können wir mehr überlegen.
Aber Doktor, ich habe gesagt, dass ich 5 Kilo innerhalb von 2 Monaten abgenommen habe.
Ich habe viel Angst. Ich habe Krebs oder?
Bitte denken Sie nicht an das Schlimmste, Herr Simmermann.
Wie gesagt, es ist zu früh, etwas Genaues zu sagen.
Mit dem Ergebnis können wir entscheiden, was Sie haben.
Aber Krebs ist das Schlimmste. Bitte denken Sie am Anfang nicht an das Schlimmste.
Muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben oder kann ich zu Hause gehen?
Jetzt werden wir die körperlichen Untersuchungen durchführen. Bleiben Sie bitte hier.
Wie lange dauert es, muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Nach dem Ergebnis können wir entscheiden.
Ich würde auf Sie, Doktor.
Bitte bleiben Sie hier. Vielen Dank für Ihr Verständnis.
Hat jemand einen neuen Patienten vorstellen, den ich eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe?
Hätten Sie kurz gezeigt?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Thomas Simmermann, ein 67-jähriger Patient, geboren am 9.7.1958.
Er ist 1,64 Meter groß und 94 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stellte sich bei uns vor aufgrund seit zwei Jahren bestehender, kolikartiger, dumpfer Unterbauchschmerzen im ganzen Unterbau.
Er hatte eine Ausstrahlung. Er teilte mit, dass sich die Schmerzen seit sechs Monaten schlimmer geworden sind.
Er gab es an, diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal zu haben.
Er berichtete, dass die Schmerzen nach dem Essen schlimmer geworden sind.
Das bedeutet, ernährungsabhängige Schmerzen.
Welchen Fachbegriff benutzt du hier?
Nach dem Essen, ich meine.
Nach dem Essen ernährungsabhängig.
Oder?
Postbrandial.
Er war vielmals wegen dieser Beschwerden beim Hausarzt.
Bisher war er noch nicht festgestellt.
Als Begleitsymptomen liegt der Meteorismus neu vor.
Er hatte gegen diese Schmerzen Uskopantabletten genommen.
Jedoch hat es ihm nicht geholfen.
Die Frage nach Reflux disnoe tachikadi dysphagy wurde verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Inapetensgewichtabnahme innerhalb von zwei Monaten, 5 Kilogramm.
Und abwechselnde Obstipation und Diarrhohe.
Die Frage nach Blut im Stuhl wurde verneint.
So wie klagt er über Insomni wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Er leidet seit zehn Jahren an arterieller Hypertonie.
Er nimmt gegen arterieller Hypertonie ein Medikament.
Einmal täglich einnehmen.
Aber die Name des Medikaments ist nicht erinnerlich.
Er hatte vor vier Jahren Handwerkinfektion.
Er wurde bei ihm stationär behandelt.
Eine Behandlung wurde bei ihm durchgeführt.
Bei ihm wurde mit zehn Jahren eine Appendektomie durchgeführt.
Es sind keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er rauche seit fünf Jahren zehn Zigaretten täglich.
2,5 Packages.
Er trinke ein bis zwei Gläser Sext.
Wochenendlich Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er ist verheiratet.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Er hat drei gesunde Kinder.
In der Familienanamnese fand er Apoplexie bei der Mutter.
Der Vater ist mit 69 Jahren an Bronchialkalcinom verstorben.
Er ist Einzelkind.
Er ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Meine Verdachtstheatomäse lautet...
Wo lebt die Mutter?
Die Mutter lebt in einem Altenheim.
Meine Verdachtstheatomäse lautet auf Reisdarm-Syndrom.
Dafür schieb ich...
Er leidet seit zwei Jahren unter Bauchschmerzen.
Er war schon vielmals beim Hausarzt.
Er hat krampfartige Schmerzen und postperandiale Schmerzen.
Die Diagnostik der Vertikulus, Ulcus ventriculii und Magenkarsinom
kommen in Betracht.
Zur Diagnostik würde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Reisdarm-Syndrom ist eigentlich eine Ausschlussdiagnose.
Wir müssen organische Pathologie ausschließen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung würde ich zunächst die Vitalparameter erfassen.
Danach würde ich den Patienten inspezieren, palpieren und auskultieren.
Palpation ist im Bauchschmerzen wegweisend.
Ich achte auf Druckschmerzen, Abwehrspannung und Organomegali.
Danach würde ich Blut abnehmen, um Blutbild, Lebewerte, Entzündungswerte und CAA-Werte zu bestimmen.
Danach würde ich bildgebende Verfahren veranlassen.
Zunächst würde ich den Röntgen des Abdomens veranlassen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich die Sonographie des Abdomens durchführen.
Der Patient ist 67 Jahre alt.
Wir sollten eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Gegebenenfalls sollten wir Ösefago-Duradinoskopie durchführen.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtsdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich den Patienten konservativ behandeln.
Ich würde Spasmolythetik, wie zum Beispiel Buskopan, verschreiben.
Ich würde eine Psychotherapie empfehlen.
Gegebenenfalls würde ich Paroxetin verschreiben.
Das war alles.
Wie würden Sie diesen Patienten behandeln? Stationär oder ambulant?
Ich würde stationär behandeln. Seit zwei Jahren hat sie vieles aus Asst besucht.
Bisher hatte sie keine Linderung.
Deswegen würde ich stationär behandeln.
Das ist eine soziale Indikation.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie würden einen Röntgen des Abdomens durchführen. Warum denken Sie so an?
Sie leiden an Bauchschmerzen.
In der Regel würden wir einen Röntgen des Baus durchführen, um eine mögliche Perforation oder Luft auszuschließen.
Also bei der Perforation können wir eine freie Luft verschweren.
Würden Sie eine Koloskopie durchführen?
Er ist 67 Jahre alt. Er leidet an Bauchschmerzen und Unterbauchschmerzen.
Ich würde unbedingt eine Koloskopie durchführen.
Können Sie die Koloskopie erklären?
Ja, die Koloskopie ist eine bildgebende Methode.
Mit der Koloskopie können wir Darm und Mastdarm beurteilen.
Mit Hilfe eines Schlauchs enthält das Schlauch eine Kamera und ein Licht.
Das ist ein flexibler Schlauch.
Wir führen das Schlauch durch den Durchachter ein.
Nach der Untersuchung sollte der Patient vorbereitet werden.
Er sollte drei Tage mit Flüssigkeit ernähren.
Nach dem letzten Tag sollte er nur Wasser trinken.
Er würde eine Abflussmittel nehmen.
Wir verschreiben diese Medikamente.
Es ist eine schmerzhafte Untersuchung.
Deswegen führen wir diese Untersuchung mit einer örtlichen Betäubung durch.
Nach der Untersuchung braucht der Patient eine Begleitung.
Kennen Sie chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankungen?
Ja, es gibt zwei verschiedene chronische entzündliche Darmerkrankungen.
Eine ist U. colitis, die andere ist Morbus Crohn.
Wir können mit der Koloskopie diese Krankheiten beurteilen.
Aber es gibt chronische entzündliche Erkrankungen.
Bei diesen Erkrankungen erwarten wir Fieber und mehr Schmerzen im Bauch.
Was sind die Unterschiede zwischen U. colitis und Colos?
Im Colitis ulcerosa sind nur die Dicken betroffen.
Bei Morbus Crohn können die ganzen Magen und Dagen betroffen werden.
Noch etwas?
Ja, noch etwas.
Jetzt erinnere ich mich nur an diese Informationen.
Was erwarten Sie bei einer Bauch-Utersonographie bei diesem Patienten?
Ich erwarte eine erhöhte Luftansammlung im Darm.
Und außer diesen Befundungen erwarte ich keine Pathologie.
Welche Risikofaktoren kennen Sie für eine Reizdarmsyndrom?
Stress im Leben oder beim Arbeiten ist der erste Faktor.
Hat der Patienten Stress?
Ja, er hat einmal gesagt, ich habe Stress.
Aber ich habe nicht nachgefragt bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Ich werde unbedingt fragen.
Und außer Stress hatte ich keine Risikofaktoren.
Weitliches Geschlecht ist auch ein Risikofaktor.
Aber unser Patient ist ein Männchen.
Genau.
Okay, gut. Das ist genug.
Herr Chefarzt, haben Sie noch andere Fragen?
Ich würde den Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Bitte schön.
Es handelt sich um Thomas Zimmermann.
Er ist 67 Jahre alt, 94 Kilogramm schwer, 1,74 Meter groß.
Er stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Jahren bestehender,
residiverender, diffusen Abdominalschmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung vor.
Der Patient hat die Schmerzen, Dumpfes und Kolikartik.
Er erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen seit sechs Monaten schlimmer geworden sind.
Der Patient war oft bei anderen Arztinnen.
Aber bei den Patienten wurde keine bestimmte Diagnose festgestellt.
Die Einnahme von Buscopan Tablet hat keine Verbesserung gebracht.
Außerdem gibt er an, dass die Schmerzen nach dem Essen aufgetreten sind.
Die Schmerzen gehen mit Metaurythmus, abwechselnder Diore und Obsipation, Neusea und Flatulenz einher.
Der Patient berichtet über eine Gewichtabnahme von fünf Kilogramm innerhalb von zwei Monaten.
Die Vegetative Anamnese ist ein Problem.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig bis auf Beschwerde bedingt.
Inapetens und Insomnie.
Anvor Erkrankungen.
Gewichtabnahme?
Gewichtabnahme.
Nein, Gewichtabnahme oder Tsuname.
Gewichtabnahme ist ein Problem.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Der Patient hat einen Problem, dass er nicht viel essen möchte.
Deswegen habe ich fünf Kilogramm innerhalb von zwei Monaten abgenommen.
Ich habe ein Problem.
Was ist das Problem?
Nein, nein.
Der Patient hat seit zehn Jahren eine arterielle Hypertonie.
Bezüglich der Arterie.
Er nimmt dagegen ein Medikament täglich.
Aber der Name, der Wirkstoff und die Dosierung sollten geklärt werden.
Der Patient ist bei dem Patienten als Kind eine appendektomische Ductgefürt.
Er braucht seit zehn Jahren ein Zigaret, aber nicht ein Nischsicher.
Er trinkt gelegentlich ein Glas Sekt.
Und Drogenkonsum würde verneint.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
In Bezug auf die Familienanamnese.
Er teilt mit dem Vater, der 69 Jahre alt ist.
Er ist mit Bronschialkarzinom gestorben.
Die Mutter hat ein Apoplex.
Sie lebt in Altenheim.
Er ist Einzelkind.
Er ist verheiratet und lebt mit seiner Frau.
Sie hat drei Kinder.
Alle Kinder sind gesund.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf Kolonirritable Syndrome aus.
Da der Patient dafür typische Symptome aufweist,
der Patient berichtet über Meteorismus,
aufwechselnde Diare und Obstipation.
Außerdem berichtet der Patient,
dass die Schmerzen ca. zwei Stunden nach dem Essen aufgetreten sind.
Und nach der Entlernung verbessert hat.
Der Patient hat viele lange Geschichten.
Das spricht für Irritable Colon Syndrome.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen auch Morbus Crohn,
Ulcerative Colitis und chronische Gastroenteritis in Betracht.
Sollte sich meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich den Patienten
die Wiedermatmete bewegen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten körperlich unterzuchen.
Dann würde ich darauf achten,
dass die Schmerzen abweichern.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Bauchgeräusche auskürzen.
Dann würde ich die körperlichen Unterzuchen
und die Diagnose auf der Unfallstelle bewegen.
Dann würde ich die Blutbildgerinnungsparameter
der Lebewerte und der Nierenwerte bestimmen lassen.
Außerdem würde ich einen Stuhltest durchführen,
um mögliche andere Probleme auszuschließen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Abdomanzonographie durchführen,
um mögliche Probleme auszuschließen.
Dann würde ich die Abdomanzonographie durchführen,
Dann würde ich die Blutbilderung durchführen,
um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Zunächst würde ich den Patienten einen Venüsenzugang vorlegen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Physik und Antispasmologie verabreichen.
Zum Beispiel die Psikotherapie.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Psychotherapie verabreichen.
Zum Beispiel die Gesprächstherapie oder die Hypnose.
Dann würde ich den Patienten die Stressverminderung verabreichen.
Dann würde ich den Patienten eine gastroenterologische Konsil anordnen,
um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind,
werde ich mit den geplanten Untersuchungen fortfahren.
Herr Kollegen, wann ist eine Koloskopie bei Verdacht auf Reisderm-Syndrom in der See?
Ja, es ist nicht nötig für Reisderm-Syndrom.
Aber wenn ich andere Kolonprobleme ausschließe,
werde ich nach akut Behandlung eine Koloskopie planen.
Und über alte Physiker oder positive Familienanamnesen Koloskopien indizieren?
Sie haben recht, Herr Oberst. Der Patient hat keine Familienanamnese.
Aber der Patient hat gesagt, sie hat 5 kg Gewichtabnahme.
Und gegebenenfalls werde ich den Patienten nach akut Behandlung eine Koloskopie planen, Herr Oberst.
Können Sie uns Koloskopie aufklären?
Ja, Koloskopien sind eine Angriffe, die wir mit Kolonbehandlungen machen können.
Diese Untersuchungen helfen uns, die Erkrankungen wie Kolonkarcinoma,
Morbus Crohn, Ulcerative Colitis, Entzündungen oder Tumoren oder andere Veränderungen
frühzeitig zu erkennen.
Wenn wir bei der Untersuchung etwas Auffälliges finden,
können wir die Erkrankungen und die Erkrankungen für die Erkrankungen in der Labo einbringen.
Wenn wir mit der Kamera einstellen,
können wir die Erkrankungen für die Erkrankungen in der Labo einbringen.
Die Unter- und Vorderunterzüge müssen für den Patienten mindestens 12 Stunden nüchtern sein.
Wir empfehlen den Patienten, am Abend eine Apfelmutter mit viel Wasser zu trinken
und morgen eine Apfelmutter mit viel Wasser zu trinken, um die Diktar zu lernen.
Diese Untersuchungen sind unangenehme Untersuchungen.
Deswegen geben wir den Patienten eine Schlafmutter, damit sie während der Untersuchungen schlafen können.
Wir empfehlen, dass die Patienten eine Begleitperson mitbringen,
da sie nach der Untersuchung nach Hause bringen.
Es gibt bei der Untersuchung mögliche Komplikationen, wie Blutungen, Verletzungen oder Entzündungen.
Die Untersuchung dauert ca. eineinhalb oder eineinhalb Stunden.
Es gibt keine Kontrastmittel und die Untersuchung ist ungefährlich.
Nach ein paar Stunden der Untersuchung können die Patienten ihre Alltagwege und die Vorsitzenden
in manchen Fällen statt der anderen Untersuchungen, wie z.B. die CDD-Aptomen oder die Ultra-Charl-Untersuchungen, durchgeführt werden.
Aber abhängig vom Krankenbild.
Vielen Dank Herr Kollegen.
Danke schön, Herr Oberast.